George marchais on a beaucoup dit et
écrits ici en France en tout cas que ce
congrès se venait une quatrième congrès
du Parti communiste soviétique avait été
le congrès de l'immobilisme ce n'est
peut-être pas tout à fait votre avis et
à votre avis qu'y a-t-il de nouveau dans
ce congrès
tout d'abord je pense que si ça avait
été le congrès de l'immobilisme la
presse française n'y aurait pas consacré
autant d'importance
en réalité le 24e congrès du Parti
communiste l'Union soviétique marque des
pas en avant important sur trois
questions pour moi essentielles tout
d'abord dans le domaine de la politique
extérieure il y a des propositions
soviétiques pour aller dans le sens de
la paix du désarmement et de la
coexistence pacifique qui sont très
importantes et d'ailleurs plusieurs
personnalités politiques chez nous on
reconnu que ce plan c'est véritable plan
de paix de nature avoir le soutien des
forces pacifiques démocratiques des plus
larges
en second lieu sur le plan intérieur le
prochain plan quinquennal va être
consacré essentiellement à l'élévation
du niveau de vie du peuple soviétique et
cela d'une manière très substantielle et
le Congrès n'a pas seulement proclamé la
nécessité d'élever le niveau de vie mais
à définir les moyens nécessaires pour
atteindre cet objectif
et en troisième lieu il y a à mon sens
dans tous les domaines un développement
important de la démocratie socialiste le
plan est basé en définitive sur une
participation très large des
travailleurs du peuple soviétique à la
réalisation des objectifs fixés ce qui
amène développement de la démocratie
avec relacru des syndicats avec aussi le
rôle des intellectuels dans tous les
domaines nous avons également eu
connaissance d'une lettre de physicien
asiatique Sakharov demandant une
démocratisation plus grande en Union
soviétique et protestant contre les
hospitalisations psychiatriques de
certains savants ou écrivains qu'en
pensez-vous je n'ai absolument pas
connaissance de cette lettre ce que je
sais comme je l'ai dit à l'instant c'est
qu'il y a aussi bien pour les écrivains
que pour les intellectuels en général
des possibilités nouvelles définies par
le Congrès d'épanouir leurs talents au
service du peuple soviétique ou à tout
ce que je je peux dire sur cette
question on parle aussi beaucoup ici de
la doctrine brégeniev de la souveraineté
limitée des pays socialistes croyez-vous
que cette doctrine existe et pensez-vous
qu'au contraire les parties communistes
sont complètement indépendants du Parti
communiste soviétique il n'y a pas de
doctrine
qui que ce soit de citer un texte
au sujet de la soi-disant souveraineté
limitée par contre ce que je sais c'est
que le Parti communiste de l'Union
soviétique lors de la conférence
internationale des parties communistes
et ouvriers à adopté avec nous un
document qui définit clairement
l'indépendance des pays socialistes
l'indépendance des parties communistes
et ouvriers dans le monde par conséquent
la doctrine la souveraineté n'existe pas